after years of drinking martin has now
been sober for almost 11 years
but despite his return to a healthier
lifestyle the damage has already been
done
his alcoholism led to a liver transplant
insulin dependent diabetes
heart trouble and chronic kidney disease
as someone who almost died because of
his substance dependency
he's not surprised that the pandemic has
led to an increase in the number of
deaths
from alcohol-related conditions
everyone's doing their best to help keep
their head above water
and look as if they're functioning into
the best of their ability
kovid has come along and it's been the
straw that's broken the camel's back
i feel and it's just been that thing
that's been completely
uncontrollable for individuals so
they've just had to take the escape
route
and that escape route is substance
misuse
sally lost her younger sister a highly
qualified engineer who had become
dependent on alcohol
just days before lockdown began last
year it meant only a handful of people
could attend her funeral
and her friends and family were left to
grieve alone during one of the most
stressful times of their lives
watching your little sister on life
support for six days after being told
she would
survive five minutes um
you know and just waiting for her to die
it's
it's it's all full it's torture but also
the years before
is a living grief you know she was dying
in front of us
according to public health england
between 2019 and 2020
the number of deaths from alcoholic
liver disease rose by over 20 percent
precovered between 2018 and 19 the
increase was less than three percent
the number of all alcohol-related deaths
also increased
by 20 percent in 2020 and despite the
pubs and restaurants being closed for
over half the year
the amount of alcohol bought in england
remained the same thanks to supermarket
sales going up
by almost a quarter health campaigners
say that deaths from liver disease have
been increasing for years
and could overtake heart disease as the
main cause of premature death
a situation caused in part by alcohol
becoming more affordable and accessible
and they warn that it's not only
alcoholics who are at risk
it's a really common myth that you have
to be an alcoholic
to get alcohol-related liver disease but
actually one in five of us
may be drinking at um levels that are
putting our livers in risk
liver disease usually has got no
symptoms in the early stages
so it's really important that people try
to stick to the government guidelines of
drinking no more than 14 units a week
and having two to three days off alcohol
every single week
public health england's report concludes
that nationwide it would help
if alcohol was less available and less
affordable
and for individuals like martin support
and education
should be available so that they too can
change their drinking behavior
and live a longer life fraser moored
sky news